how reject nation it's Greg Albee here
with finely tailored over here Taylor
Robinson
she knows reactions on her own channel
as well she does some great videos on
there make sure to check them out
I meant Taylor at Collider Studios a
couple months ago she came up to me
she's like Greg I'm your biggest fan
don't tell your boyfriend that is what
she said that's exactly what yeah she
don't tell your boyfriend hey we're
gonna watch ultracarb in netflix trailer
today this joy came out like a week ago
but we've been getting a lot of requests
to check it out so we're a TV series on
Netflix it's just doing really well in
Netflix Asia hey let's find out we know
a little bit about it you dye your
consciousness gets transferred into
another body yeah it's like your spine
[Music]
yeah yeah I think that's how I was born
yeah okay
[Music]
[Music]
that's a long time to be dead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's so much going on I know
[Music]
nice
nothing to see
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
Osia protecting your ass yeah she says
speaking your tailor what do you think
you go first I got so many Blade Runner
vibes yeah oh absolutely
[Applause]
it's like more action heavy version ibly
you know especially your like with the
fight scenes because there's actually
martial arts choreography bloody runners
I'm known for its action but in terms of
like set designs and visual like the
cinematography does feel very Blade
Runner reminiscent which is cool to
bring to a television show I think oh
absolutely you do so much with that on a
television show I guess would has me
slightly off put by it is it looks like
an exciting adventurous sci-fi show I
love the opening of its concept what it
looked like eerie and creepy and dark
and mysterious and exploring the
philosophy especially when you have like
a Blade Runner looking aesthetic which
is all about exploring a certain type of
philosophy and having a debate I feel
like that kind of all got canned in this
trailer for action sequences and visual
imagery which still looks cool I was
really drawn to the idea of the world
exploration because it's like he wakes
up we put your mind in another body and
now you're on a mission to find a
murderer focused on exploring that
concept of waking up 250 years later in
a new body yeah that's insane you I
can't even imagine what that would be
like to wake up and see how much the
world has changed yeah in two hundred
and fifty years and if the show focuses
on that aspect heavily I'll be very
excited for it if they kind of did what
the trailer did and they end up just
caning that mostly for cool as it seemed
like there was a lot going on I know
this is a TV show trailer too so I have
to keep that in mind that they're trying
to like tease a whole season for you
guys at the same time like what is the
core of what this show is about is it a
murder-mystery show is it a sci-fi
exploration shows at a philosophy debate
show what are the exact themes here
besides that one can
CERN it's a Netflix show so I feel like
it would probably do is that Ryu from
the Street Fighter movie I think it is
at 24 second it's all I wanted to
comment on the rest of the video doesn't
matter what I say okay so we just play
back a good amount the trailer and
actually watch it I'm like you know what
the show does look pretty sick yeah it
does look pretty cool they're saying
like the expositional lines of we have
to solve the mystery everything but
there's a whole mystery at hand at who
the main character is to that I'm more
intrigued by more than whoever the hell
this guy is he was like you need to
solve my murder
absolutely I'm very much I'm like wait a
second what happened to this guy that
[Music]
but he's your main character he's your
protagonist I would have liked a little
bit more intrigue into that I mean he
looks like he's gonna be a good actor in
this he looks like he's doing a decent
job is anyone else concerned that that's
the actor from Suicide Squad that army
guy that had all of the worst lines in
the entire movie she's vulnerable stab
her in the heart yeah that guy let's
hope his acting is better in this than
it wasn't Suicide Squad just saying I
hope next time we see his ass yeah but
this seems like a show I'll definitely
check out I'll wait for the rotten
tomatoes to meet it and tomato meter
yeah what about you know probably what
okay yeah deck of the fall the crab way
I roll all right well guys thanks for
recommending that to us you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos as up taylor is
finally it says slow watch the last
video why he does reactions on her own
channel she actually knows how to talk
about [ __ ] and that's why i invited her
on this channel because she is a good
commentator make sure to subscribe to
her channel make sure to check out our
patreon it's like a second youtube
channel videos over